with all these dominoes falling it it
does
make it interesting about deshawn watson
right
i don't think any longer he controls his
destiny with
like you can control your destiny but
with the no trade clause
if the texas want to move him they're
going to say hey here's the one team or
two teams that
that we're going to be able to move you
to this is what we're doing take it or
take it or leave it type thing but
you know all the teams now are getting
close to being set for 2021
so perhaps it is at the trade deadline
perhaps it is
at the end of the year but i just think
a trade for deshaun watson
is really being backed up now mike if
they're gonna get
any sort of value for him at all and i
do think the value for him has fallen
and and in my mind desean watson
has been removed from the front burner
of nfl news
and rumor and possible transactions now
it's on the front burner of off-field
issues but as it relates to his football
status his football future short-term
and long-term
i i think that we need to accept the
fact that he's in limbo
and he needs to accept the fact that
he's in limbo
and everyone out there who thinks oh
this is just something that's going to
be resolved by
may or june you're really not paying
attention if you think this is all going
to neatly
be cleaned up and everything's fine
no suspension no commissioner exempt
list
there's another lawsuit today we're
going to talk about this later they're
up to 22 and there's a criminal
complaint that's been filed
i think we just need to look at desean
watson as a guy who's a non-factor
in 2021 at least as it relates to the
quarterback carousel and that may be why
shireen the 49ers eventually said
the hell with it let's give three
first-round picks
in exchange for the third overall pick
in the draft plus a third rounder and
the panthers said the hell with it we're
not going to wait around to see what's
going to happen with desean watts and
we're going to go get sam darnold
and just kind of take desean watson off
the board
as it relates to the possibilities of
him being with anyone
in 2021 if i had to bet right now and
this isn't
i i i do you know i'm not suggesting
that anyone should go out and wager on
what's going to happen with these
serious off-field issues and they are
serious
but my hunch right now is if i had to
pick a spot right now does he play or he
doesn't play i think it's more likely
based on what we know now that he
doesn't play this year
yeah i agree with you mike and maybe
it's something they do in the offseason
somebody eventually is going to take
deshaun watson he's going to play
somewhere he's too talented we know that
we've seen this too often
but i think this off the field stuff all
has to clear up and as you said it's not
going to happen in the next month two
months three months
so he's either gonna there's a lot of
possibilities here but
he's either gonna play for the texans or
not play for anyone i think in 2021 and
whether that happens
at some point during the season at the
beginning of the season or not at all
uh we'll find that out but it's not
going to be cleared up over the next
couple months mike
there's one caveat and this is important
and and we need to
recognize now that a criminal process
has started we don't know where it's
going to end
we don't know how compelling of a story
the complaining party is going to be
able to tell we don't know whether or
not a prosecutor is going to decide to
try to get a conviction
of deshaun watson on serious charges
that could put him behind bars for a
very long time
we don't know who else is out there that
may decide to go to the police we know
that desean watson has denied all
wrongdoing but
news flash that always happens
everyone always denies it if there's a
way that the dominoes fall for deshaun
watson in a court of law that gets him
convicted
he may never play again so that's at
least got to be
a dot yeah even if it's on the outer
edge of the radar screen
there is a chance he never plays in the
nfl again
because his entire life comes collapsing
down
on a stream of criminal complaints
become prosecutions that become
conviction so
this really is a serious serious matter
and that's why in my mind
you just it just it's no longer
a football matter he's off the table
until this thing is resolved whenever
it's resolved and you know what if it
gets resolved before the start of the
season
then all right he's back on but he in my
mind he's off the table
until this all gets resolved because i
don't think it's getting resolved any
time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports